well I've you know I've had so many
great meals but but you know a part of
it is just like the context you know and
that's another thing that chefs really
understand it's like you know there's
great cooks and there's great chefs and
chefs I think understand that context is
just as important as as as the food so I
talked about food stories you know I
think that that plays into that not that
I'm a great chef but I think that that
it's an important aspect of being
something more than just you know kind
of ego driven chef but but the other
part of it is like controlling the
context so that's very hard to do
especially in midtown Manhattan you know
or anywhere i'm at is very hard to like
get people think about other things than
their job their hectic life and and
again i point to Mario Batali I think he
does it well you walk into his
restaurants and you get a feeling for
something that's much larger than than
just the food that's on the play and my
own personal experiences you know I was
stashing I was doing this internship and
in France for for several years even and
at the end of it I treated myself I took
a page I've a down to the south and I
had a meal when Alain Ducasse was really
just starting i mean he just gotten
three stars at louis quinze and he was
you know the he was the the
up-and-coming guy me now he's most
famous chef in the world but back then
he was really in the kitchen and I I had
a meal that I'll never forget because it
because you know is my last time in
France and it was just like it was
something really to behold because I
everything sort of came together at that
meal was extraordinary meal and I
remember crying over the pea soup but I
guess I was so tired to add some rundown
and I just remember eating his pea soup
and just crying because it was just like
it was such an expression of of southern
France and it was like it had all these
Italian influences and it was very light
and and you could see the future of
cuisine I was tasting it and I've been
in Paris where was quite tradition I was
working a very traditional old-school
restaurant there are lots of butter and
cream and delicious and and great but
you know you you saw this this this
thing that was not just a master at work
it was a master at work within the right
environment that that conveyed that as
those kind of meals are just like
they're so priceless they know so I mean
it was a three-star restaurant so it's
like it's a little predictable that you
would have this great meal there but I
actually did it actually really
delivered on what it's so hard you know
like it's so hard to walk in a
restaurant and have the expectation
level we the press you know they tend to
play up so much and the you know these
these chefs and these restaurants you go
in you I feel like nine ninety-nine
point nine percent of time you're like a
little bit disappointed you know so it's
those chefs that can either really reach
those heights and they can't just do it
through the food and those are the
best chefs know that or you go the other
way like the David Chang's of the world
who you know under-promise and
over-deliver you know and that's the
great that's a great quality of chefs is
when you can have an environment in your
restaurant that you walk in you're like
a little bit like you know you're the
ceilings are low or your your you you
look old there's there's paper on the
tables like in Blue Hill New York or you
know the glassware isn't so great and
then all of a sudden the food comes out
it's just blow away incredible you know
and and and and it's that way because
it's met your expectation actually
exceeded in that's when does that ever
happen in this world it would be today
it's like whether it's a movie or
whatever it is it's like it's always a
little bit disappointing from what
you've expected and so when when you
have an experience that can meet that
next page or even superseded it's like
then it's just incredible so controlling
the context is that is a big part of it
and that's a fight in New York and one
of the great advantages that Stone Barns
has which is you know we're out in this
idyllic landscape and we have the
opportunity to control people's context
and people's understanding of what
they're eating and that's you know that
that makes me again look like such a
better chef
you